donc ce soir nous recevons bois
brassband bonsoir à tous les deux donc
ma Tito calera vous êtes le batteur du
groupe et Alexandre Mons vous êtes le
saxophoniste
vous avez une formation plutôt originale
comment est-ce qu'on peut vous définir
alors comment est-ce qu'on peut nous
définir donc on a une fanfare déjà donc
c'est une fanfare c'est il y a une
rythmique et des beaucoup de cuivre donc
saxophone trompette subasophone donc
c'est le gros truc comme ça
on voit pas
très bien
de l'équipe qu'on va pouvoir
à la base normalement c'est des musiques
de Banda ou de ou des musiques
militaires mais là donc là nous c'est
plus ce ska jazz et Balkans enfin
principalement balkanique en fait
d'accord et alors en fait vous êtes pour
la plupart d'entre vous vous êtes 7 en
tout et pour la plupart d'entre vous
vous êtes issus de d'un premier groupe
d'une première formation et vous avez
souhaité finalement mettre l'accent
plutôt sur la fanfare
pourquoi pour quelle raison
donc bah en finale enfin donc la
première formation s'appelait Alonso boa
donc il y avait aussi Jonas et Pierrot
qui sont pas là aujourd'hui donc avec
matchdo et moi donc ils vont font des
groupes et du coup ben on a tourné
depuis 2005 sur ce projet là et souvent
en fait on jouait déjà en fanfare dans
la rue enfin en fait on avait une
déclinaison de ce groupe là et où du
coup on trouvait que ça marchait quand
même beaucoup mieux que ce qu'on pouvait
proposer sur scène vis-à-vis du public
et enfin le répertoire qu'on proposait
enfant phare était un peu plus pêchu et
plus adapté
aux salles peut-être un accueil
différent non pas forcément mais c'était
vis-à-vis du public puis bon avec Alonzo
bois c'était plus un peu plus
expérimental comme musique donc c'était
moins commercial on va dire du coup
c'est fin c'était un peu plus réservé
déjà un public
trop de style dans un groupe et du coup
on jouait
peu et on jouait dans que dans des
salles en fait là on peut proposer à
tous des mairies des festivals des fêtes
de villages des fêtes foraines tout en
fait sur différents
enterrements alors peut-être pour qu'on
se rende compte de ce que vous pouvez
donner sur scène je vous propose de
regarder un extrait donc d'une de vos
chansons avec une petite particularité
puisque vous proposez également un
numéro de contorsion vous avez une
contorsionniste
alors et ben donc là c'était une autre
une autre soirée il y avait pas la
contorsionniste
vous avez qu'est-ce qu'elles sont vos
prochaines dates ou est-ce que vous je
crois que vous faites une tournée un
petit peu à travers la France pas
simplement sur le département
on va jouer au monde en pas longtemps là
où fin mars
il y a aussi une date à Blois c'est
24 mai le 24 mai on va jouer au festival
contemporain à Mantes-la-Jolie donc ça
c'est le 28 juin d'accord donc voilà et
puis vous avez un album en préparation
voilà où on part s'enfermer là dans au
colombier à magny-en-ville donc c'est la
fin à partir du 11 mars là donc très peu
de temps du coup voilà on va enregistrer
tous ensemble
en novembre prochain et puis l'album
s'appellera Amadou housse donc avec un
petit particulier enfin particularité un
petit une petite reprise de Mozart
enfant phare mais bon j'en dis pas plus
vous découvrirez ça
n'hésitez pas à nous transmettre vos
extraits merci beaucoup en tout cas
d'être venu
cet extrait de contorsion on va le
découvrir à présent on a remis la main
dessus on va regarder ça
voilà comme ça on l'a vu ce numéro de
conscience
à la fin de cette édition du 7